Many of us have become quick to discover the delusions / visual tricks used to deceive our eyes - but how I thought there were
There are illusions / audio tricks? Are you really able to trust your ears and the things you hear?
For example, listen to Greg talking ...
What do you hear? If you heard "bar, bar, prevent 'you are right ... but, what about now?
There is a possibility that you heard 'away, away, away' this time, with 'F'. Except, you did not - in fact, we originally did not change the sound
Between the two videos. Despite what seems strange, what you hear depends on any video
I was relaying. Come on - rotate in every video watch and you'll see how that sound
turns up. This is an excellent example of something called the McGurk effect, which shows how far
Our vision can change what we believe we are hearing
Now I want you to count how many times you see a circle flash on the screen. Let's do it
one more time. Have you seen the flash twice? Many people did. However, without a voice, it
It becomes clear that the circuit went only once. In this case, the sound may change
You have vision perception.
This next workout works best with others around you. I will play two tones and tell me
Whether they are upward or downward. In other words, are the tones playing from the bottom up
Or from top to bottom? listen to this.
Hey he? What about these?
Write down what you heard for each number, and share your answer in the comments. the odds
That you get different answers when comparing your answer with enough people will be great. Surprise? Try more.
And this.
How can you hear something different from
Others? It's the illusion / audio phishing called the paradox of Tritone. We have been designed
The nangmas so that they contain both the highest and lowest frequencies in them, but our minds have them
A certain preference to listen to either. Diana Deutsch, designed this trick, found it
That geography and language of childhood all play a role in determining this preference.
Finally, listen to this soundtrack of the melody gradually rising.
However, if you are running the same
Exactly again, it will look like it's continuing to rise higher and higher.
I swear to you that this is exactly the same section, you can repeat this part of
More and more video and check your own. Try it! Each time you play the melody
Apparently the mounts are higher. This is called the Shepard tone of musical deception, which it has
Many variations. In it, many linear waves are played one above the other in one package played waves on one top and another lift
, While one quickly drops down to the octave with the continued rise of others. But
Our brain does not notice this drop, so these passages seem to be rising ... forever!
These tricks may help explain how something like music can have a profound and uneven effect
Our minds, we discussed in our new AsapTHOUGHT episode here, along with the question
Music can save your life. There is a link in the description to see it!
So ... Do you still trust your ears?
You have a pressing question you want him to answer? Ask him in comments or on Facebook or Twitter.
And if you want a head start for the next episode ideas behind the scenes,
Check out our Instagram and Twitter accounts.
Subscribe to get more science videos weekly!